i i agree we can use liberalism against
itself until a certain degree
but we do we do need some goals in
common beyond the tactical aims you know
beyond that beyond the tactical little
steps like
little victories here and there are
awesome lula one in brazil we have boric
in chile you know we have petro in
colombia like beyond those tactical
victories we have to go beyond and say
okay good so now lula is still
negotiating who owns the amazon but now
he's negotiating with uh with with some
benefits to the brazilian people and
he's like dude really
and at the moment here in the city we
have water cuts every day
so i only have water in my house from
four in the morning till 11 a.m
then i don't have water in my house the
rest of the day
yeah
right now
it has been like that all summer and
it's probably gonna be like that until
september when we get water again with
the rains okay and i'm talking about the
third biggest city in mexico we have
over six million people living here
and it's a very wealthy city actually
the the the little
uh that one of the little spaces in the
city is one of the wealthiest
neighborhoods in all of latin america so
it's not a shady
backyard type of not it is a super well
developed cities with lamborghinis and
ferraris on the street and we have water
from 4 a.m till 11 a.m in the morning
every morning but at the same time
it's in this city where we have heineken
and coca-cola
and they consume
millions of liters of water and they're
constantly asking us for take faster
showers
[Music]
hello listeners
i come to you with a heavy heart um and
the listeners of course are both the the
humans listening to this and these
scripts that are crawling our audio
on the pill pod we've had a few mistakes
along the way
you are you're gonna share your shame
with the listeners
very rarely are those mistakes
mine
but i would like to publicly apologize
to our guest who's who i will introduce
you to in a second
because never in the history of the pill
pod has there been a mistake
this big
which is we got half we got half an hour
into talking about stuff and it was fire
but you'll never hear it it is lost to
the sands of time into the abyss
that is the pure past
but we're going to record it again so
thank you for our to our guest for uh
sticking around so this is
an episode with uh victor and i
a co-host combination that we've uh
never had before as far as i'm aware no
i don't think so
so for the last month or so although not
sequentially we have been looking and
re-looking at the idea of communism and
all that is implied by both the words
idea and the word communism so just to
catch you up on that the idea of
communism was a series of three
conferences uh that which were
subsequently put into books
addressing that age-old question
what do we do now
particularly in light of the financial
crisis and that would be not the current
but the last financial crisis
and so they dragged all of these
celebrity marxists out of their uh
dingy
offices and
put put put the task to all of them to
decide
what the academic response was
to
as to whether communism is really good
for anything anymore so that's what we
are addressing again today but at the
moment
if you want to detect the the echoes or
reverberations
uh reaching us from some non-capitalist
future it doesn't look like
any anglo
country or even any any you know quote
unquote western country
is headed in that direction so
as we
and uh probably a lot of our audience
and
almost all of our source material on
this podcast whether it comes to
political theory or
or what to do next
is somewhat stuck in a little bit of an
anglo-eurocentric
box and because we can't trust any
english language news coming out of
latin america for some obvious reasons
we have invited
diego
rosario
who we
now have both talked to for half an hour
but uh diego i'm wondering i'm wondering
for the listeners
who may not know you
you're probably the most famous leftist
that uh
i've never heard of until we started
talking on on instagram but what the
hell would you put on your business card
yeah like at parties
you don't have business cards but um
i don't know what the hell i will put on
my business card something like the ceo
[ __ ] something like zuckerberg
no just kidding um first of all thank
you guys so much for the invitation i
was i was telling you guys just before
we started the second recording first as
far as now a strategy that uh
that is this episode of the peel pod
that i'm that i'm having a huge cringe
fan out because i've heard pretty much
every episode from the pillpot i'm a
huge fan since i started stalking you
and you responded to me on instagram and
on twitter i said guys this project is
way too cool for people not to be
listening to this i really want to be
part i want to participate help as much
as possible so first of all i'm really
thankful for the invitation and i i
really respect the work that you guys
are doing uh even even if ideas don't
matter i i think it's a it's it's a cool
effort regardless it's a aesthetically
pleasing effort of nothingness if you
can say something like that
having said that what what's on my
business card about how will i introduce
myself it's kind of weird because um
i'm a content creator i do a lot of
youtube well at this i've done a lot of
youtube for the past two years but i'm
active in every social media i have a
little team of of people that uh that
have been like following me since the
beginning and they wanted to collaborate
so i make them like partners uh in under
like a cooperative organization so we we
we create together they help me edit the
clips and edit the videos and then we we
split the profits as much as as we find
uh feet and just to the amount of work
and and talent that is required for the
for the end result
and um i'm currently working on a
documentary regarding the politics and
economics behind soccer around the world
especially for uh marginalized groups
and how they use soccer to send a
message under this idea especially since
the world cup is coming in november is
going to be in qatar highly
controversial because of many political
and socioeconomical uh implications so
i'm at the moment i'm passionate about
that project and for our listeners you
got to respect he comes in here and he
modulates for you by calling it soccer
when no one in the world
calls it soccer and diego the one other
thing that i want to get out of the way
is
you told us you're not a leftist whereas
like the only thing that i would be able
to just identify you as is a leftist so
what are we talking about there
i don't identify as a leftist definitely
because i don't i don't find
any leftist political
projects that i can relate to because i
i think and and this is where or where i
think we can transition into the article
um in latin america what we have is
especially nefarious brand of leftist
populism
that seems to disguise itself under
leftist notions but don't really
challenge any of the key underlying uh
real
effects of of of of current life so
that's why i don't necessarily identify
as a leftist
so if you're an anglophone and you
search up diego's name on google you'll
find
the debates
the lectures
the interviews now he's a documentary
filmmaker it's about
what would you say 80
spanish 20
english
around something like that yeah i've
been growing a lot in the us lately a
lot with latin communities in the us
which i found
is a huge huge market but i will say yes
the split is around 80 20. i guess i'm
curious about like so how did you start
what's kind of been your trajectory to
become
as we in our first version of the
recording so uh
your favorite title become this
political influencer you know what was
what was the journey from
from kind of like
being just someone who's interested and
i think you you maybe you can tell me
tell us again about some of like your
own um personal connections to
philosophy as well and then like how
maybe that led into where you are now
sure so like i'm a designer by formation
i have a a mastery degree in experience
design i study uh the designers tell us
that i didn't he does
it is it product design or or like not
only that
my specialty is in food design oh
yeah yeah like packaging
no no no no no much much more
complicated than that it was [ __ ]
amazing to be honest with you like i
this is this is the first part of my
life and i was a really like a big
capitalist pig to be honest with you
like i was climbing the ladder i work in
the multinational company i was forced
to wear suits i was giving presentations
about innovation and strategy in new
york with ceos and shareholders like the
first part of my life i was really into
fast-moving consumer goods like the food
industry to be honest with you and my
specialty was understanding the
relationship between humans and food
what do we get the pleasure the pleasure
from eating and
the first part of my career i travel
around the world and i publish like 20
books about street food
about what people eat on the street and
why trying to understand
from the beginning from a very designer
point of view what was the relationship
between portability ergonomics price
point uh culture history
techniques of cooking available uh
utensils like and how this transformed
and shaped the relationship between
humans and food and that got the
attention from big companies i got
higher from from pepsico to be honest
with you guys i work with pepsico for
like seven years yeah i know
i know and then and then i discover
something nefarious it's not just
i think that nefariousness was there
from day one you're married to a
lacanian psychoanalyst
what did she think about you running
around
basically writing on the desire of food
well to be honest that's how we met we
met when i was doing exactly that and i
think that's what got her attention at
some point because i was talking so much
about desire and pleasure and everything
and she was like this guy has no idea
what he's talking about he's so cute you
know like this [ __ ] like he's trying
to impress me using words that don't
make sense out of the contest of la can
so yeah we we we got off like really
well at the beginning like i was you
know like i had no idea what it really
meant to talk about desire and pleasure
i was only talking about desire and
pleasure from the capitalist logic about
how to drive consumption i had no idea
and and now when i look back i just saw
your video on this idea of consumerism
and how marketing traps your desire and
it's i would love to get into this
conversation with you and give you a
bunch of real life examples of how your
video applies to how this actually
operates in the real world because it's
scary it's it's fascinating but at the
same time super super scary so uh
because i could i could only make that
because i also have a background in
marketing but it was uh web marketing
not food but food sounds a lot more
interesting
it it was man it really was because in a
way and now because i'm reading uh
mauricio luponte and also hustler like
phenomenology is one of my favorite
fields but i i just look back at my
career and now what i'm doing with
soccer and i'm trying to apply a lot of
these ideas of embodied
embodied experience
uh to the notion of food but also to the
notion of soccer and and that's why i
keep falling back to this to this to
this notion that the only thing i can
identify as is as a materialist
like beyond beyond materialism all the
other tags and stuff that you can apply
to yourself are just like so hard for me
to identify with but materialism i just
can't shake off is is like i keep
getting back to what i just want to say
quickly that i love how in latin america
and continental europe they're still
looking like practicing leukemia and
psychoanalysts that would be so rare to
find
in north america but i remember hearing
in fact i think i even have an uh like
an ant in chile do you think
psychoanalysis works works in english
no i think it does i think it can i
think well
i mean i i like lacanian psychoanalysis
as you if you listen to our episodes you
know that i'm a big fan of jiji and
lacan in spite of my you know my lib
tendencies i love that stuff um
but i think uh
i think it works i i'm so i actually not
to like take the conversation off
totally off the rails but like my mom
and my stepdad they're both in
therapists and like one and in fact my
stepdad was pr was studying when he was
younger as a medical doctor to become
a freudian psycho psychoanalyst
but i think what he found is just that
psychoanalysis one of the faults is that
it's a little bit too sometimes depends
on the therapist it ends up reifying the
method the technique too much and it's
like obsessed with the technique
and that kind of is dehumanizes the kind
of connection between the patient
and and the therapist so that was his
problem with it and he he's he's he
identifies more as like a humanist
therapist like
and some of these people who he's
influenced by are actually like you know
phenomenological psychotherapists too
which is a little bit uh but he doesn't
really believe in method so i think i i
think a lot of the insights of
psychoanalysis are really good in terms
of like how well they work i think i
don't know but i i think it it does seem
like
psychoanalysis can be vulnerable to
people getting too obsessed with doing
the method correctly and then not maybe
paying attention i don't know what you
if you think about that if you've ever
talked about that with your with your
wife i i think that i think that well if
we incorporate the loose critiques of of
psychoanalysis
and and try to reconnect it back to
zizek even if zizek never actually read
the loss is that um the notion is to
apply like this
and he hated it oh yeah but he he he he
read it in the least uh let's say the
least nicest way possible like contrary
to what the lord said he said there was
a good philosopher and his name was
deliz and then guitar he came along and
ruined it no yeah he said got to get he
should be shot yeah
that joke is amazing no but what i like
what i like about well what what's the
relevance of talking about
psychoanalysis today and if we connect
back to zizek and and my notion of
materialism
we talk about psychoanalysis still
because psychoanalysis in a way to
reverse
uh
marx dialectics to analyze super
structures to reveal material conditions
but that's my reading like beyond beyond
that i think that the
the policy like
not not policy let's say
police-like behavior of psychoanalysis
can be detrimental and in a way it was
very much instrumentalized to
to create a normative desire in in
current conditions so i think there's a
limit to psychoanalysis but it's not my
field of expertise i know i'm going to
get in problems with my wife because of
saying this but but regardless i do
believe there's some value in
psychoanalysis into revealing the
underlying material conditions that end
to
end up showing up as a psychological
behavior
yeah i mean i've been through years of
psychoanalysis and i've only found it
helpful but
then there's a point where you're like i
need to go live my life outside of this
kind of like it's kind of like shifting
to offline
you got to live your life offline
outside of the outside of the office
well i guess just quickly to comment on
your on what you said about not
identifying as a leftist
anymore and i wonder if it's consistent
with i think something that i've said
before which is i think there's always a
problem with isms
in that like at least myself i like to
think more about specific human problems
people like things that can make
people's life concretely better
and i think that like whenever you you
you it's easy to become a slave to an
ism right because then you feel like oh
i have to connect everything back to
like is this truly leftist is this truly
whatever and it's like to me it's like
those things don't matter it's just like
what are things that make sense in the
context of what we live and i think
that's actually why which maybe we can
get into later i think some of my
positions end up coming across as like a
little bit liberal because like my
reading of the way things actually are
and like not caring about being some
pure leftist lead me to conclusions and
i guess and i wonder if like your move
to just say well i'm just a materialist
is also in a way being like well we just
need to pay attention like the context
of people's lives
um and like what is that are actually
the things affecting them i don't know
if would you agree with that
well i'm to be honest with you i think i
think
ideas emerge out of condition and we
don't necessarily change conditions with
ideas like this is this is what is very
hard for me to to commit to like do
ideas change the world really when like
to to an extent maybe but
are these new ideas just a fa just just
a reflection of some underlying real
condition that is actually shifting
beyond our con our control or even our
ability to recognize and then these new
ideas emerge to describe the fact that
new material conditions are are being
tangibilized in reality that's that's
that's that's what i define as
materialism is is not uh it's not a
radical uh you know physicalism where
i'm i'm not a monist i think
i'm still within the realms of
dialectics but i just think the subject
is a symptom
i i don't think i don't think the
subject itself is um
it's a it's a pure affirmation it's a
it's a spontaneous event
that's that's why i'm so
uncomfortable and so i have always this
distrust on the that we have to rely on
subjects for change because subject
subjects are a symptom
we are a symptom of language we are a
symptom of material conditions we are
symptoms of relationships of power so
again it is it's hard for me to try to
justify that subjects are the cause of
something
for me subjects are the effect of
something they're not the cause so
that's why i identify as a materialist
because i still believe the idea of
subjectivity is mostly an illusion is
it's a it's a self-created fantasy this
narrative fallacy that story we tell
ourselves about ourselves
that's why i still
you know even trying to make sense of
this of this notion that we we should be
talking about material conditions where
i think most mostly lefty politics are
talking about fantasies narratives
identities and subjectivities and and
people don't really don't really grasp
the notion that these subjectivities
they are result of something else of
something that came before it of a
material condition that was the cause
for these objectivities to emerge that's
that's why it's hard for me to identify
as a leftist like most most of the
lefties today are idealists they're
modern
like
for for god's sake like like still
mostly the leftist politics is modern
and that's for me is a is a disaster
yeah i mean i agree i'll get into some
uh real world examples here because i i
sure i don't know that i've really
thought about it but
leftist is the one label that i have
never denied
there's a bunch that i would deny and
that one's not one of them
but
uh we in the anglo-sphere and our
angloid audience are uh
we we looked to south america like in
the last year uh i think since uh
what is it march or february uh we see
the elections in chile we see the
election in colombia we see lula back on
the rise
so
if you are a
non-no just a non-leftist i guess
victor and i think we we've agreed that
both of us are non-partisan leftists
but if we
if we look at this it it seems like good
reason to be excited
and i think probably our audience is
excited about it because you know
nothing's going on up here
is kind of the narrative that we have
like we're we're dealing with uh
our
lib
prime minister and
whatever is happening in in britain and
then we got biden bumping into walls
right below the border
so we look to to uh latin america as oh
there's like a a wave or a push or
something something's happening
somewhere at least even if it's not here
but it sounds like you're pushing back
against that a little bit so what would
you say
with regard to uh what's what's being
called the pink wave
right so this is interesting like for
for me growing up in
in brazil until i was 10 but then after
that mexico and i've been traveling
pretty much all over the global south
for the past almost 30 years of my life
is that we never really believed in in
democracy and i think this very much
relates to what this act normally says
it's like we
we know but we don't want to know so we
don't know right so we
we know that democracy is fake
we know that democracy is corrupt but we
really don't want to know because it's
too hard to think about alternatives to
change the world so so we don't know we
pretend like the next guy is not going
to be corrupt so so we play along okay
and and this is mostly my analysis that
um
the way latin america explains the world
is with the structure of south soap
operas with novellas right so there's
there's this structure there's this
narrative there's always the hero the
villain meritocracy is always part of
the story if you if you work yourself
hard enough you can pull yourself out of
poverty there's there's an opportunity
waiting for you people still believe in
the lottery like it's social lottery
financial lottery whatever the the
bitcoin lottery exactly we we we believe
reality is structured like a novella
like the structure like a south opera
and and it's it's is interesting because
soap operas don't go anywhere like you
can go into netflix in south america and
and some 80s soap operas are still
number one trending
we haven't been able to go past them
there's one very famous from colombia
called betty lafaya which is betty the
ugly secretary that i think is still
number one in latin america and netflix
is insane we're still trapped under that
fantasy and that's and that's how i
think is our relationship to democracy
as well even if it's it doesn't matter
what you believe it's how you act i
think you guys said it in a podcast as
well it doesn't it doesn't matter that
you identify yourself as a marxist as an
anarchist you have to vote you have a
passport
you're a subject in a way you're subject
to and you're a subject from this this
notion of structured realities that is
reinforced through habits and acting
is what you do what matters not what you
think so if you vote and you have a
passport and you have to renew your
license you're a liberal it i mean you
can think whatever you want to think but
your acts on the world just say
otherwise and and that's why i think
that even if people
have this and i i think populism in
latin america is being is being the
scapegoat of hope
damn no it's like we are we are unable
to dream about an alternative so we just
paint capitalism under different more
amazing more friendly colors that's it
that's all we can do
our our freedom today is we're free
everywhere we're free for everything we
can be naked on the street we are
challenging all criterias about
sexuality we are free we are even
challenging this notion that we can live
forever under these artificial
intelligence that can be downloaded into
an amazon server that then your family
gonna have to pay rent for you to
survive but we're free to think about
whatever we want but we cannot raise
taxes we cannot limit the mode of
production we cannot challenge the
property of common goods those things
are beyond freedom so what i think is
that politics today especially in latin
america but i also think this is a
global disease is that we are allowed to
talk and challenge all way only those
notions that don't really change the
underlying material conditions that
actually produce reality
i mean true true so uh
just just for the listeners we read just
a really short section of
g x answers without questions which
comes from
the idea of communism series i think
it's book two but i just wanted to read
this a little bit because it lines up
with what you're saying the recurrent
story of the contemporary left is that
of a leader or party elected with
universal enthusiasm promising a new
world and he puts in brackets mandela
and lula
but then
sooner or later usually after a couple
of years they stumble upon the key
dilemma
does one dare touch the capitalist
mechanisms or does one decide to play
the game
if one disturbs the mechanisms one is
very swiftly punished by market
perturbations economic chaos and all the
rest
and kind of what you're describing this
seems like it might be a split between
maybe your generation
in the global self versus our generation
in the global north is like
the suburban white kids
up here are realizing this
they're our parents all believe in
property our parents all believe in uh
democracy and it's
it's only now that these cracks are
starting to show for
you know what we call our generation and
and mainly the younger generation which
is either to just completely check out
of the system i don't want a part of it
or to realize this is bad and it's only
going to get worse
yep
i think i think it's related to social
mobility
because in the 70s even if it was still
very much skewed
under like democracy was skewed to
fulfill the interests of capital which
is which is in a way my reading of
neoliberalism i think that social
mobility disappeared and now the
conversations we're having and the
agendas proposed for the economic future
is you're gonna own nothing and you're
gonna love it
that that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up
on so many different levels we're
talking about a future where everything
is up for rent of course in this type of
uh it's type of an inver a dystopic
inversion of the idea of communism
and well my my
tanki
guillotine owning
left its landmarks's side kind of like
it because if there's less bourgeois to
decapitate it's probably going to be
faster
so god
so i'm just going to close my my tanks
is there acceleration it's not an
institution to violence but we if we
only have to decapitate seven
billionaires is gonna be much easier
guys so so let them let let us play as
uh accelerationists for a while and
let's pretend like five guys own every
one of the commons but they already laid
the technological ground for actual
communism to exist which is great but
the issue is that right now we have a
sort of dysfunctional dystopian
communism where one guy owns the
intellectual property of 80 of the world
and we have like bill clinton has bought
how many acres of land in the us for
agricultural production it's it's insane
like the guys doing the last two years
of pandemic the guy hoarded up on
agricultural grounds in around the
united states so as soon as we say okay
thank you for hoarding it all all up now
we just take you out of the equation and
we and we syndicalize it or we make it
into a cooperative and we own it the
ones who work it we we've gone we've
gone into that direction but my my
concern with this is that um we are not
having the discussion that we need to be
having about property which i think it
should be one of our main concerns we
keep talking about you know painting
democracy under different colors making
democracy less inefficient and and of
course it will be better yes it will be
objectively better but what we also have
to think is that for someone in the
world it's always too late it's always
urgent revolution is always late for
somebody for for a mother yesterday in
ghana with three kids revolution is
already too late so having having this
notion of having only aims but no goals
it's dangerous to me because it it leads
up to a to a to a to a type of passivity
that is that is um self-patronizing in
the sense that ah it's going to be
better marginally better and in a way we
change as much as possible for things to
remain the same
all right so very based
i don't disagree
and the revolution
yeah the revolution is always late for
somebody but then my question is
what do i do tomorrow
do i get a brick and
walk up the street and throw it into the
window of a td bank
is that going to help the woman in ghana
so when we're talking about aims and
means as we've been talking about for
basically weeks here
what are we doing what are we doing here
and now
that matters or how do we even measure
how it matters
so i'm putting an interesting
position here between two people that i
respect and both of whom i've heard
uh talk a lot about this
so victor on on one hand we've heard the
fire brand
property is the only issue abolish
private property nothing's ever gonna
get done and then we've have like
your your mantra which is
institutions are bad and you agree with
that but also that institutions are
important and can be reformed so i was
wondering what the other side
of this uh
teeter-totter is gonna look can we have
institutions with no private property
then me and victor will be really good
friends
um so okay so i mean i kind of wanted to
ask i kind of wanted to push you on on
something else but maybe we can like
this will be related but i wanted to
push you on not wanting to identify as a
leftist because i guess
in hearing your concerns about and
actually pills said it earlier that uh
him and i both kind of identify as we
sort of say non-partisan leftists and i
guess i just see leftism as an
orientation towards
like what's gonna make people's lives
better uh what's gonna make people what
it seems like people want
and i guess i guess i'm hearing a lot of
in what you're describing kind of you're
concerned with property you're concerned
with alienation
like that sounds like a normative
concern right like to me that doesn't
seem that different
than being a leftist right it's like you
know so i guess i'm i'm wondering i
guess i'm hearing like a kind of crypto
universalist like like like claim about
what the good is
uh well still trying to den or am i
hearing it like kind of a denial of that
but like everything that you're hearing
clearly sounds motivated by a sense of
justice
and i guess or might we say why idea of
communism
yeah yeah which which is a perfect segue
into the topic so this notion that marx
was a crypto normativist or or or crypto
moralist even worse uh it's it's it's
weird because i mean you can give them a
moral reading to some of mark's pieces i
i guess you can but the notion is that
why do we need to change material
conditions especially to the means of
production is for new subjectivity to
emerge oh why does that matter who cares
if if there's not enough it matters
no i i mean the sense the sense of
justice is in the sense that today what
we're trying to fix is the symptoms of
current existing subjectivities
oh yeah and the
the marxist analysis is that well you
you can fix the symptoms as much as you
want but you're never touching the
underlying conditions the only thing
that is actually going to promote
something new to emerge is the change in
the material conditions which is in the
end property
right okay no i i don't disagree i guess
i just want i i guess i just do think
that you have a sense of justice
underlying your perspective so i think
that you well yeah the reason you matter
yeah like like the reason those things
matter the reason you're concerned with
property it sounds very clearly to me
motivated by like
what some ideal of the justice so i
guess that's all i meant so like and and
i just feel like that is being a leftist
like i think that like that is
if if if you want to if you want to i
can i can i can i can take that that
that nomenclature i really don't mind
but for example one thing that would be
mandatory for me to consider us as a
marxist or as a leftist even it's the
idea of collective versus individual
that for me is fundamental if you if you
don't think collective is first and most
more important and constituent of
individuality then
then you cannot be a leftist
yeah that's interesting i mean i i i
tend to think without
that they're kind of to use heideggerian
language they're kind of equi-primordial
i think they both like exist at the same
time i don't think you can give one the
priority over the other i think
neo-liberalism has given us has made us
give individuality much over a priority
but i still think that it's a mistake to
be like well the priority is to
collective i think that they're
equi-primordial which maybe we don't
have to get into but uh yeah but
i think i think this this primarily i
think you guys have scratched this topic
once you got it you got into this
conversation once for like five minutes
and then you drop it and i was like oh
my god i really wanted to hear your
takes on this because here's your chance
yeah and i and i want to if you can if
you guys can elaborate i would really
love to because i think most most people
tend to
oversee
this they might be historicism like i
don't know if if it's it's not even
philosophical it's more like history of
philosophy but to get this notion of
are you dialectical is it material
before idea do ideas even matter ideas
exist before before matter or
the collective constitute the subject or
the subject is born and then his
affirmation on the world changes
collectivity like i think even if these
notions are overlooked they tend to
in a way
domino effect into your views of the
world
and and that's why that's why i think
like most leftists today they are
idealists they are modernists and they
are voluntarists
that that's why it's so hard for me to
identify as a leftist because
fundamentally i don't agree with any of
those three i don't believe in personal
merit i don't i don't believe ideas
fundamentally change the world and i
don't believe in individuals can change
the world so
like even if i i if i agree with social
justice like your fundamental notions of
the world are are are foreign to me
right
right yes
yeah pills oh god well put me on
all right well i mean you guys already
know what i think it was the whole last
episode
so
if you walk up to someone on the street
and you ask
hey are you an individualist or a
collectivist that's an it's a
non-question
if you if you want to go back to the the
means by which
you would identify yourself as an
individual in the first place they would
be
collective means
you are never
on your own your language is not your
own as you've as you've said your being
is not something that you are just
in control of and that you
self-determine through life but i also
think that
the context in which diego is bringing
this up is political
and in political i think very obviously
there's no such thing as individuals
individuals are useful placeholders or
personas or figures and any talk about
heroes and villains all falls into this
trap is as if
individuals make history which i think
that is uh demonstrably untrue okay well
why well i mean
well i mean i know diego's curious about
like what you think about i mean i guess
the question is like
i guess the question is how like
what what what has priority like kind of
at a maybe ontological level like like
what like what is like what's the
underlying and i guess i mean i was
describing that i think like these
things are kind of equip primordial
meaning that like i think the individual
like and this is i think influence from
you know you mentioned diego you're
reading marilyn ponti right now and i
think to me like merlot pontian
phenomenology i i think they're they're
like my reading of it is that it clearly
shows that kind of the experience of the
other and then the experience of like
individuality meaning that there's like
an alternative between you and another
person which kind of gives us a sense of
individual like i think those two things
are co-producing at the same time you
can't have like i don't think there's a
collective experience and then that
creates like i think both are kind of
happening at the same time
um and then i guess the question is like
what are the kind of implications of
that for the question of like property
and capital and i don't know if i have
an answer for that but that's my view
but can can i give you can i give you a
radical materialist reading of what you
just said sure like for example let's
say so i was born in south america right
the food my parents ate constitute their
genetic
build
and it was passed on to me
so the macro engineering of using corn
as the basis of elementation for our
generation has an effect on our bodies
and and this was this was before us
before any individuality emerged you
were constituted by the effect of corn
on your parents
and any potential genetic predisposition
you can have on the world
like in that sense in that sense
material conditions are always before
not only individuals but any ideas that
can emerge the more we study about but
gut biome and gut health
the more we understand what what freud
wanted to do with with bo analysis
you know psychoanalysis in in and even i
don't know in which freud's book is is
this text but freud said that he knew
the limits of his practice because in a
way he could not describe the
relationship with the body into an
emerging psyche and i think the more we
study genetics and biomedicine and epi
epi medicine the more we understand
everything comes from our material uh
constitution from our material uh
mind if you want to say it from the this
merlot party idea of of your embodied
experience but your embodied experience
has a history has a material history
where were your parents born what type
of of genetic diseases they have what
type of vaccines do they receive what
type of food they ate their their
relationship to nature this constitutes
what you can think
so look you can see what you're saying
with
with the description but what you are
offering is a description you say look
if we go back we are corn and you can go
back to to whatever we are the food that
our parents ate and their genetics
but you have to also understand that
there's an observer
in that equation yeah and then that
observer right now like being you or
being the person who's who's writing
this analysis
of the fact that we are not just
ourselves there's also a position there
of observation that is also not strictly
material this is not a strictly material
analysis in the way that you're framing
it because there has to be someone doing
the analyzing and the analyzing is where
the things that we associate with the
individual come out also as important
you know thinking
so diego i want to ask you if this is if
if property is the only thing that
matters if property is a thing that we
have to go back to
if
everyone who is not talking about
property is a fake leftist and of course
we're always we are always on the look
for or we're always on the lookout for
these fake leftists um then why would
you make a documentary about soccer
instead of
property yeah
the last worst enemy is the left
it's insane
i don't go to that extent like even if i
i don't like openly identify as a
leftist especially when i'm talking to
anglophones and in the sense that you
guys have a notion of the left that is
very foreign to us is is
you know especially the united states
relating liberal point of views to the
left is so hard coming from from marx
it's super hard because you end up with
this antagonism between individual
freedom and individual effect on the
world versus material conditions and
it's for me it's always super hard to
reconcile but having said that why did i
the reason that i ask is because very
materially
both you and i sit in front of
cameras and microphones
and we film and that's most of our day
so i'm trying to get i'm trying to get
you to answer that connection between
what what do we what are we doing
if
property is the thing that matters
because you know i tend to agree with
you that property is the thing that
matters but if we are just like in
involved in this uh constant flow of
internet communications we've got to
game the algorithms we've got to do all
this stuff where's the connection
between like the the soccer part of it
and the property part of it so
i have i have different
lines of flight you could say or like
different
lines of of
of
work that i want to accomplish with what
i do okay the first one of them is uh
capital umano okay so like this these
t-shirts that i send you guys like the
the branding that i use everywhere
capital um capital
why do i say capital mono because i want
to raise awareness of these um that
we're still proletariat
that we're still spendable that we are
just one variable in a system that has
no moral judgment that uses us as one
other variable
in something that doesn't concern us you
know the proliferation of capital
doesn't care about humans and the
proliferation of capital doesn't care
about nature it has its own internal
logic and we are one variable within
that logic and that's completely amoral
it's outside of moral judgments right so
that's that's capital umano
the other line of of of work that i do a
lot is uh it's the other sentence that
made me very famous that was the one
that i use on the debate is why do you
believe that would you believe
is in spanish
okay so it's a question that i
constantly ask everyone that i interview
everyone that i talk to to reveal the
fact that ideology still operates in the
sense that there's a there's a there's a
con there's a there's a super structural
construction to your view of the world
that helps you explain reality even if
it doesn't necessarily has any
connection to reality itself okay and
then the third line of work that i line
of work i could say or line of
research that i do is the
dementification of meritocracy
and i know meritocracy is probably not
as nefarious in the global north because
it's partially real
as it is in the global south
meritocracy is this sense that the
harder you work the better is going to
be the results
and this is measured by a bunch of
indexes like the genie index which
measures social mobility and in latin
america it has been alive for decades
but people still believe in it
and soccer is one of the fields where
people still believe in meritocracy
where they believe that you have talent
and you've put the hours on it it will
make it you will be famous and you will
have money and you will lift your whole
family out of poverty
this is the myth of soccer and that's
why i think soccer is still a very
proliferous myth that is so big and so
huge especially in the global south
because it has the structure of a soap
opera
you can still think and it and it ends
up behaving like
a monotheistic theology
in the sense that you choose a country
then you choose a team then you choose a
player and you glorify and you create
this
you know diego maradona and you and you
have this i went i went to visit the
church of diego maradona in argentina
and there's a church that legal church
of maradona in argentina i was baptized
under the church of maradona which is
going to be a great part of the of the
documentary but what i want to show is
this notion that even under soccer
meritocracy is a lie
even under soccer not those with the
best talent are the ones best rewarded
and even under soccer if you don't own
the field you cannot play
they have to ask for permission to play
they need a ball they need a space
and there are some fundamental things
that are outside of the scope of the
main narratives that people are not
bringing up forth right so this this is
why i accepted the documentary and i
gave it my spin in order to introduce
the the conversations and the talking
points that i wanted and and this is
this is drastic pills and like the main
issue and one of the main issues that we
discover is where do they play soccer
who owns the field who runs the field
and like for example we had we had an
episode because it's going to be like um
28 episodes of five minutes and then one
full hour and a half full documentary
and we had the story in the amazon river
about a floating community where they
even living these floating houses in the
river near uh the amazon river actually
near the rio negro which is one of the
two rivers that constitute the amazon
river and they don't have a field when
the when the river is high because
during raining seasons the river goes up
by 23 meters and the fields disappear so
they have to rent a little floating
field and we had to transport the
floating field to the city so they could
organize a soccer tournament
so there's there's this like i there's a
sentence that i love is that if politics
is water is war by other means soccer is
politics by other means
that's what i want to do with the
documentary would you also say in that
line then that like is is media
war by other means because you are a
you're a media
creator and like so are victor and i by
by other by other media
but is that is that like a a space worth
fighting for is it a space worth
um like
can can you put it on its head just by
talking about it
because this is it's hard you already
referenced me
in this uh interview saying ideas don't
matter and that really comes to the
heart of
what i mean by ideas don't matter is
like if if i were to if i were to say
all right i'm going to shut this all
down i'm going to shut down the media
my our like my my channel my whatever
and i'm going to go do something i
wouldn't know what to do and i really
don't know what to do i don't have that
i don't have the capacity to
understand all this
like
oh if i have a political
theoretical outcome in mind then i can
realize it i don't i don't know what any
of that is
i'd actually be interested to hear what
victor thinks about that too please
please victor go ahead
um
like what i what are you asking me pills
like in terms of
if if diego what diego is saying is
right like if you are a leftist your
issue
is property
then should you be
managing like what you do in a day only
based around that or can you do a
documentary on soccer and bring in the
property aspect and is that a sense of
consciousness in the material
historicist
sense that is real
yeah i mean i do and i mean that also
brings me like i want to ask diego some
questions about like like property
because i know
there's a couple things so like
maybe a way into that
would be to ask you about something that
you said earlier diego you kind of made
this distinction between aims and goals
and i wasn't exactly sure are you saying
that like the aim is kind of like the
the direction we're going in and the
goal is kind of like the end point
exactly right so and you and you like
yeah okay okay and aims make more sense
to you than goals right because goals
are no i think necessary okay okay i
think both are necessary and this is
exactly the point about talking about
the idea of
of communism
because is the goal still relevant or
are we just talking about aims and we
change aims every year
you know this this is why and going
going back to appeals to people's notion
so pills is hard because you say okay
in the end even talking about property
it's in the realm of ideas
even talking about property isn't even
even believing that talking about
property can have an effect on people is
idealism
yeah right i kind of think that's true
yeah it's it's hard it's super hard
because then debates are completely
worthless conversations are worthless
because they're all symptomatic this is
all symptomatic
of of real material conditions so what's
the point of doing it then this is this
is why i think zizek is still relevant
because his notion is that we use
psychoanalysis to reverse back to reveal
material conditions
that's why i think i think conversation
should be around the realm of of
property because maybe we can get some
trauma
well what about property like like so
how should it change like i want i'm
kind of curious about like concretely
you say we need to talk about property
in what way
like like so for example at the moment
one one of the main economic concerns is
the collapse of aggregate demand
right so
people have less and less money to spend
we are more and more productive than
ever our productivity keeps going up and
salaries are
flatlining right so what happens in
economic basic economics is that you
have a collapse of aggregate demands
people produce a lot but they cannot
even buy what they produce and max marks
foresaw this i mean this is not new we
have been in this trend for the past
since the 70s at least and and more and
more we throw away what we produce
artificially because people cannot
afford it and we don't we don't even
believe the market can self-regulate so
it's easier just to produce more trash
hide it into the ocean or in some remote
island in africa and produce more and
just like have iphone 14 and 15 and 16
instead of rebating the leftovers so
people can actually afford uh in a way
related to their to their salaries right
so so this this artificiality created by
the market and again this is not outside
of capitalism man this is this is
capitalism like people that criticize
this and say no this is effect of
canadian um new uh neoclassic uh
economic logic on on capital no no this
is capital it marks for saudis like the
rate of of margins are going to grow
thinner and thinner as as we progress
and and
the the future world that is proposed to
us it's a world of rents
it's a world of no property where all
property is congregated in very few
hands and we have to rent everything
this is the world that is proposed to us
and and why is it scary because we
already have climate migrants
climate refugees
we have people in soccer that don't have
fuels people that don't have their own
houses and we have these hordes of
homeless zombies living in main cities
in america and this is happening all
over the world and and densely populated
cities that are you know
and that's why i connect back to my to
my own son and i become very very
egoistic in this in this notion
because i know from very first hand that
we're all going to be handicapped very
quickly
our ability to produce money and to even
pay for the rent of the things that we
don't own is going to disappear
it's a window what is the story with
your son
ah so
so my first son paolo
he actually turned 10 yesterday happy
birthday and uh he was born with a very
very weird genetic disease he's 1 in 50
million it i don't even know the name in
english is a very complicated name but
he got diagnosed into autism and then my
wife
started researching and this is this is
incredible my wife doesn't give
interviews but i swear to god she's like
the most brilliant person i've ever met
in my life she's a la canyon
psychoanalysis but because of my son she
started researching uh medicine
and now she's like a
cons like other doctors call her to talk
about genetic medicine wow because of
the events that she had made with our
son it's incredible incredible the
diagnosis we had is that he was going to
be unable of speech and he was going to
lose partial motor functions by the age
of seven or eight and now he's 10 and he
has a vocabulary of around 100 words but
he's still fully fully functionable uh
in his body functions so just because of
supplementation and different type of
exercises and stuff that my wife
discovered can you imagine the trauma of
being in a canaan psychoanalyst and then
having a son that is diagnosed under
autism and then discovering that the
problem is the body it's the alien you
imagine that like it was it was super
intense yeah and shield she still
practices uh psychoanalysis she still
has like 30 40 patients in
psychoanalysis but now she always
connects psychoanalysis to the body
you know like like there's no point
talking about your depression if you
don't if you don't if you have a lack of
b1 vitamin
like if you don't fix b1 there's no
point treating your depression and and
for me this is this is bioanalysis like
this was freud's dream
for us to be able to connect the symptom
that is the subject to the body which is
the source right so when because of my
son because of his genetic disease i
started reading and i started
researching because i got really
paranoid as a parent i was so he's
condemned to be homeless
you know the the reality for
for uh for
how i don't know how to say it properly
in in english but
diverse functionality how do you say it
in english neurodivergence
not neurodivergent like the the body the
body type
physical the functionality because in in
in spanish as diversity functional
functional diversity differently abled
different label exactly so yeah so the
current politically correct version of
of disabled is differently abled right
but it's still a capacity notion it's
still a notion that your worth is
related to your ability to produce right
so under that notion i i got really
scared because my son was condemned to a
welfare state or to homelessness and in
latin america they're pretty much the
same
and and it got me really scared and i
got to research about these and and what
was the future going to look like and
under this notion if you connect the
dots between
collapse of aggregate demand
hyperindustrialization and hyper
productivity automatization and the
disappearance of able its jobs and the
disappearance of welfare state
what you have is a large sum of
population that is not going to be able
to pay rent to live
and if you don't own anything you will
have nothing
but nothing on a level that we cannot
even understand today
that's that's why i believe property is
so important because in the future the
opportunities to produce money are going
to be very scarce
salaries are going to be collapsed cost
of rent is going to be extremely high
and every it's going to i i foresee
we're going to live in a world where
utopia exists for like the one percent
and 99 are going to live under [ __ ]
you know like uh
elysium you know one district nine one
of these these topic movies from the
from the from the last decade have you
heard of this example diego i i i don't
wanna i don't want to say the wrong car
brand but i believe it was bmw they put
seat warmers in all the seats
but you need to have an app that you pay
15 a month to to unlock exactly seat
warmers exactly so it's just going to be
a complete world of micro transactions
where you don't own
anything
even if you buy it
anyway the example of you bringing up
your sun like this really makes sense
what you said earlier on which is this
uh
this uh
firebrand rage you have against the
idealism
of the left
so the idealism of the left in terms of
you know we have to
i don't know whatever fantasy it is we
have to overthrow we have to guillotine
we have to do this
and i i kind of want to like
negotiate some sort of uh
truce between what i know your views are
and what i know victor's views are is
there an institutional way to do this at
all because we could like you're from
mexico and we are from canada so we
could talk about the united states until
we're blue in the face we know
the united states is it's a failed state
it's [ __ ] up yeah um but is there is
there
any sort of democratic alternative um i
i it sounds like what you're saying is i
don't you don't have much
faith in this pink way i prefer china
okay
wow
okay you don't have much faith in this
pink wave
necessarily you don't have much faith in
institutional reform um
victor
despite being a lib
is actually very intelligent and very
articulate on the topics of
institutional reform and he focuses on
that and then reads it all day so i
wonder if there's like some way to
negotiate between these two positions as
sort of a
a a closing down arc
because
you're saying we're done
diego and victor saying
yes i agree that everything is [ __ ] but
we're not necessarily done with it all
yet
well it's kind of interesting because in
a way like i don't know i've been
listening to diego like give his account
and i was thinking to myself well i
don't disagree
with any of the kind of like you know
diagnosis of society
um and i was trying to figure out okay
well am i just
more pessimistic about the possibilities
or like more pessimistic about change
and like you know i have some other
notes written down of things that i
maybe want to bring up questions about
subjectivity which maybe we won't have
time to get into which i think informs
my views about like what a kind of
possible future is but then that all got
thrown totally uh haywire when you said
that you prefer china and i was like
okay well that's over the u.s oof any
day oh okay over the u.s sure uh no i
still don't know what other options do
we have as latin america the issue is
that i don't know if you guys can relate
to this notion but um there's there's a
there's a punch line in in latin america
where we say we are too far from god and
too close to the us
that's that's our doom why we are doomed
as a continent or as a region because we
are too far from god and too close to
the us
yeah
that's funny um we're the shady
manufacturing backgrounds
that's that's what we are we are we are
the labor camps of the global north
it's true i mean that's latin america
and that's the global south to be honest
with you if you take away a couple a
few very rare examples and i used to
live in singapore i also have to add
this i used to work with chinese banks
and chinese companies i know how they do
business and how they operate and and
there's a lot of propaganda about the
the way china works
that is that is brainwashing you guys
completely completely completely is
insane like this is
the demonization of china and it's it's
still is still michael bay is is michael
bay in the same sense that top gun is
glorifying the the navy and the army
like this demonization of the
alternatives it's still the propaganda
machine like
yeah it's true that china is buying
africa and it's buying latin america but
the rate of interest is lower than the
fmi
so
yeah
wait what is fmi
uh
uh
international oh i am f in english
international monetary fund yeah because
the imf is gougers with their with their
interest rates i mean that doesn't
surprise me
we are born in debt
we're born this this is this is insane
can you imagine like i know the the talk
is getting too political for pills but
like in in in in mexico specifically
25
of the taxes captured by the state are
used to pay the interest of the national
debt yeah that's that's my up
yeah this this notion this notion that
depth is not hereditary it's a lie we we
are all we are all born in depth
yeah of course so but like back to this
question of china and
you know i think that the concerns that
i have i mean i i don't doubt that some
of the stuff we're told is is untrue
but i i think you know ultimately um i
think my concern with with input from a
political theory perspective is like i
want some grounds for
whatever sovereign government over me
i want there to be some
thing that i can see that makes sense
that makes it legitimate like like
legitimacy right so like you're you're
too modern for me victor
like yeah you're too rational for me
you're trying you're just trusting
rationality you're trusting rationality
it's too romantic for me my friend no
but you just
you still be real you still believe with
rational beans no not at all no no no
not at all not at all so this is my
thing
in institutions no no so it's not it's
not that i actually think that it's like
it's a very like even materialist like
point i think that like you you need the
government to have something that makes
them legitimate and one of those things
is like to keep you safe is like the
basic is like a basic like this is kind
of like a thomas hobbs point this is
like a very i want to materialize his
defense on this point in that he has
very little faith in human rationality
which is why he thinks institutions are
necessary
yeah a big other is necessary yes
the big other is not outside of your
mind the institution is just to make it
so people don't kill each other
that the institutions are like a big
other no then well they function that
way they can function that way
ideologically they can but you need
someone who's going to punish you if
you're gonna go like
steal your neighbor's lawn furniture
but then again i go back to this notion
i really don't disagree with
institutions my problem is with property
can we have institutions without private
property then then then i'm then i'm
into it
so maybe i mean it depends what we mean
by private property and like so and and
then like pop what's what's the what is
the negation of private property so what
kind of a human relationship it's like i
guess i think we need something stable
that that that like at least gives
people a sense of st like uh some sense
of semblance of trust
that like there's some reliability in
their life and when i say reliability i
mean that in their everyday life they
trust that like someone isn't gonna
arbitrarily come and just like take
their stuff away or like kill them for
no reason right we need some stability
oh yeah yeah absolutely
so there's
sorry yeah so so i think so so i think
like to me like that's really all i mean
by institution and like you know you
might not it sounds like you don't even
necessarily disagree with that it's just
like it seems to me that like private
property
again like like there's a kind of
vagueness to like exactly what what we
mean by that because you were like a lot
of the kind of um points you were making
earlier diego were about you know uh no
one's gonna be able to own anything
anymore right so like to me i was like
thinking to myself okay well so you do
think that people should own things um
but just maybe not in the conventional
sense right it's like people need to
know yeah yeah yeah
okay so two things first there's a
there's a line by gote
gotha i don't know how to say it in
english
there's a line by gotha that i
absolutely love that is that i prefers
i prefer injustice to disorder
right and and i think is what is what
you're saying that you prefer a certain
level of democratic imperfectibility to
chaos to anarchy to the lack of
institutions because you don't have even
a framework of regulations and in order
for injustice to be recognized because
if we don't have a framework of
institutions who determines you know
moral law good and bad crime punishment
we need social institutions and that's
actually the first argument against any
libertarian point of view
yeah the the notion of private property
only exists under the state
because you need somebody to recognize
private property if you don't have
somebody to recognize property property
doesn't exist you know you can say you
can own anything but if somebody doesn't
recognize someone with an authority
doesn't recognize your property then
what do you mean by the legitimacy of
property it's a completely empty claim
right so in that sense i agree with you
i prefer a certain level of injustice
than disorder i agree that's why i said
and and my notion to move in this
direction of property and what i mean
about property marks marx has a
differentiation between two types of
properties there's private property and
individual property
so you can own things of course you can
own things but the question i raised
today is about the property of commons
is about the property of territory of
land of natural goods of technology of
in in some that are super new like
intellectual property
like data
you know like why why are those
privatized unders
i mean they are owned but they are owned
by very few people under
very questionable means
that's that's my challenge so it's not
it's not about you know that again i
think we're talking about the thing the
same thing in different time moments
like i agree with you in the aims but
we're probably disagreeing in the goals
or or we haven't discussed if we have
the same goals because probably the aim
like the mid steps we agree like i'll
say what i'm talking about is that we
discuss about property why
because today like
very few of us is gonna own their own
houses
and probably all our parents have their
own houses
like we don't even dream about it
anymore we're just like we we normalize
the fact that we're gonna rent until we
die
okay and and there was a certain degree
of
and you see this this is why i cannot
skate marx and i would love to and i
swear i'm not dogmatic i would love to
get out of this argument but it's but
it's hard to escape because i remember
my parents like once my parents he told
me once okay i paid for my house now
what do i want to do
i will never be able to ask myself that
question
i will always be scared of being
homeless
like can you imagine the logic of
productivity like destroying your
subjectivity because you're always
scared of homelessness
you don't think that has any effect on
our subjects it's it's insane of course
you do like once you pay your house once
you have a place to fall dead and fall
ill
you think about different things
like what are all these different things
that we're not thinking about because we
care about homelessness every day
this is my question about property this
is my challenge to property there are
some certain basic things that you need
to to live
that capitalism is taken away from you
little by little and transforming
everything into a centralized ownership
that rents everything out to per to
people that have less and less
acquisitive power every day and to jobs
that are disappearing
like this this is the materialistic
criticism of capitalism is that you
you're gonna own nothing and you're
gonna have no option
yeah i mean i agree i agree with that
like for sure i think
maybe where there's like a slight
disagreement as you said is like the
goal and
you know i think my like i don't exactly
know what the goal is like i don't have
like a a fully fleshed out thing but i
guess i have concerns about
um like so i think in our when we first
started recording that the the version
we don't have i i think i kind of
mentioned to you because you asked me do
i think that uh you know that capitalism
is necessary and i think i said that
like
it's leaving the free market yeah like
or and i think my answer was like well
it feels really hard to imagine like
some overarching structure telling you
that like you can't exchange these
things for goods and i think like so so
i think to me like that kind of private
interaction of people being like well if
you give me this then i give you that i
mean this is like a very human thing
that that all human societies have done
it's just become the markets are not
capitalism yeah well right exactly okay
so they're so good i think we agree on
that distinction distinction then so
like so like it's a very strange
question do you believe in the free
market because
there is a market of course they exist
but that's the separation there is of
course
existence
the free part of it is the question we
should be asking oh yeah so no all
markets are not but but i think there's
also a question that i have about
subjectivity because i think
you've said you said a couple times
something along the lines of like the
kind of subjectivity that's created by
capital that's created by our private
property paradigm
and i wonder this is kind of a
philosophical question but i wonder like
where do you think that it sounds like
when you're talking that you see
subjectivity as being caused by these
structures
um
and i tend to think that well these
structures are also kind of a reflection
of subjectivity also so it's like you
see so you're you're an idealist you
believe ideas come before matter
uh no no no so i think so i think the
matter actually so i think like the the
the markets and these structures that we
have are a reflection of like the
material conditions the material body of
like how we are so like you know and i i
think like that's like um for example
like lacanian psychoanalysis right like
the dialectic of desire this like this
this like um like it's impossible to
quiet this dialectic of a desire that
like you're always going after the
object and it's like i think but in a
way capitalism fits that now i don't
like it i don't like the form that it's
taken but in some ways i think we
learned to desire
we learn what we desire but the
structure itself like the fact that
we're going to fall into this pattern of
like desire satisfaction desire
satisfaction i think that means
i mean it's a fundamental yeah it's
fundamental so i think like in some ways
that structure in subjectivity in my
opinion spontaneously creates these
structures that that may be lead to
these outcomes so that makes it a little
bit more interesting
a little bit because
i've i have
completely shifted on this in about the
last six months or so
thinking this is how this is who we are
and you kind of learn this in like our
our high school class people are greedy
people are gonna seek their own interest
um
but i i really wonder which comes first
whether it's the social conditions that
tell you you you can be successful it
doesn't matter who you [ __ ] over it
doesn't matter which community you start
from if you really want to make it to
the top
you can screw over everybody and you can
make it there
and i want to know
i really this is not a question that
i've solved at all
but i don't know what kind of
people
we have
outside of this system
and for example like david graber the
new or the new book
um yeah he i haven't he really tried to
unearth this i don't really like agree
with the analysis but i really
buy the project of like what we what we
are as people
as like a an organism that has been
alive for 180 000 years or whatever it
is we don't really know what we are if
we're born into this raised in this and
die in this and that's the only future
we see that's the only past we see there
is something else that i
believe is possible
and unfortunately victor i'm not going
to be able to say here's what we could
try out here's what we could do i don't
want to be miss i don't i also don't
want to be misunderstood so i'm not
saying that like you know capitalism or
this kind of like perverse
kind of like systems that that like lead
to this perpetual like like
accumulation of more more and more i'm
not saying that that's destiny but what
i'm saying is like
i think because of the way we are we are
vulnerable to those kinds of structures
emerging and i think that potentiality
is always there we're talking right
we're talking about human nature
yeah so it's not destiny but it's like
we are always well i guess but so we're
always going to be vulnerable to being
captured by these things so you're
getting a free market you believe in the
free market you believe in human nature
and you believe in the institutions
but but i believe in the canadian
psychoanalysis and and marilla pontian
phenomenology i mean that's where i root
my my accounts of of the human beings
of all the critiques i give of
liberalism victor never falls into them
because he never believes in the best of
people he believes in the worst no i
don't which is that well
politics is self-interest that's
actually one of the reasons why i don't
like some marxism is because i don't
believe in self-interest i don't believe
people know what their self-interest is
like i don't oh yeah people don't know
what they want people people are taught
what they should want that's the issue
it's like it's like we are aliens
arriving in a country that is playing
soccer and we believe the objective of
life is to score a goal yeah this is my
reading of criticism of capitalism
i like that no like like we we arrive at
this moment in history we are trying to
make sense and create categories to
describe what we are observing and
experiencing and we we create our
okay i'm going to be like
forgive my explanation because this is
definitely not my strongest field but my
notion of of the birth of subjectivity
is uh
master slave dialectic
so
within the master slave dialectic there
emerges a sense of self in the in the
the notion of the recognition of the
other right
what what marx did to inverse the day of
dialectic is to say that the slave that
is not recognizes that doesn't get
recognition from the master
looks for
for work and nature to create a sense of
self
so our sense of self comes from our
relationship to to the world
how we build our life and how we relate
to the world and this i think is
validated by merlot pontia and a lot of
other thinkers and correct me if around
who was the thinker that brought this
notion of masters dave dialectic into
france and had a huge effort on a lot of
kojev maybe jean-paul certainly told you
that's right okay that's right so okay
so my so my notion of subjectivity i i
still i'm still in the marxist reading
of the masters they have dialectic from
hagel so we we we lose in some in some
level in some degree we lose the battle
of recognition we want to be recognized
as a self uh uh
auto conscience of uh where consciences
but we lose this and then we then we
then we go to nature to discover who we
are
but within capitalism alienation happens
because we are never able to identify
who we are because we never get
recognition from our work
we are alienated and out of alienation
it's the birth of pretty much everything
that is with identity politics it's
everybody trying to discover an identity
to be somebody in the world to be
recognized as something someone as a
preference as an sexuality as whatever
but we can never be fully be fully
satisfied by this because there's no
material fact in the world that give us
that sense of self-confidence so that's
that's why i'm i'm an advocate for this
sense of of materiality and property
because like the type of questions that
my father asked himself like okay i pay
for my house i have food on the table
now what should i do
this opens up new possibilities and what
i'm afraid of is that we are we are
being
cut off from these new possibilities of
imagination because our desires are
trapped under the machine of capitalism
and not only capitalism but liberalism
as well i i for me it's harder and
harder to separate them that's that's
that's my that's my my philosophical
argument for why i believe discussing
property is the only way we can open up
for new subjectivities and this is not
cryptomoralism i don't think it's going
to be fundamentally better
the this is where i stand my ground i'm
not saying it's going to be more just
i'm not saying it's going to be better
i'm just saying it's going to be
different and
in this and in here very delusion i much
rather go for the creation of new
subjectivities than to to stay trapped
in this nostalgic nightmare that we
cannot get out from the past five
decades
so that's great
i agree i agree with with almost all of
that i think i think maybe i'm more i'm
trying to locate like where i stand on
like maybe this question of subjectivity
and like and new possibilities and i
think in to some extent we share very
similar pessimism
but on another sense i think i might be
more pessimistic in the sense that like
maybe you could correct me if i'm wrong
but i think i'm hearing you you know
these kinds of new subjectivities and
also like alienation like i'm a bit of a
skeptic when it comes to like
unalienation like i think we're always
alienated there's no way to not be
alienated i think there are like
concrete specific examples of things
that clearly like owning your own labor
power like
like having more control over like um
your the your material conditions to me
and i i do i'm not scared to kind of
moralize it like that just seems good
that seems better to me okay um but then
but this idea that like you know new
subjectivities will emerge that will be
less alienated like i i don't even know
what that means like i think i think
that like we are by nature that the
thing this is where i'm kind of a
likanian like i think i think that like
uh alienation is like a condition of
possibility for our subjectivity like
for our the desire the way that we are
alienated by the symbolic like this is
just a a feature
and it's not something we can ever get
out of we can we can find i think we can
locate concrete things that will give us
more autonomy and more control
but i don't see that as like a different
subjectivity i just said that i was like
if i can if the symbolically if i can
give just an example of of something
that seems to have survived
the uh the capitalist spore
reproduction
is the family
like in your in your family you have
people that you don't like you have
people that you do like they remain your
family you have the weird uncle you have
the
the grandparent that says stuff you
disagree with and these are these are
i think it might be our only like little
cloister which is even being dissolved
today
but it's the only little cloister of
relations that are completely
outside of a market and
you know if you want to think of
new possibilities not really new
possibilities they're really old
possibilities but to to think of
of humanity as a fraternity
which might honestly which
might honestly not be possible
in today's world with the size of states
that we have
with the lack of
you know intentional community that we
have maybe not but like you have an
example with your family of
of a community that is not based on on
market relations it's based on social
relationships
absolutely
like for example like i take care of my
kid not because i get something in
return well you could say you know
there's there's a there's this beautiful
sentence from
a quadriplegic that is a philosopher of
capacity in in spain called javier de
romaniac and this is actually something
you guys could benefit from like there's
a lot of philosophy in spanish that is
not translated that is beautiful like
gustavo bueno javier romaniac ernesto
castro but borges of course but there
are some other thinkers that could be
great but this guy has a sentence that i
love that is that um
which would translate to
those who allowed others to take care of
them
give meaning to caretakers
right so like this this is what i think
you mean pills when is is not
necessarily a transition
but is his subjectivity as a result of
of social relations right
you know like social relations of
character that's kind of what i got from
the from the graber book even if his
historiography is a little bit off but
he the point of him writing the book
and his co-author i forget the name
but the the point of the book was like
this is not the only way it could be
this is not even the the way it's always
been
exactly
exactly i think i think that that
history that rewriting history is to
erase our cognitive bias to
individualism and self-worth
and to give a more collective
tint to history but i will be and i
agree with you with the criticism to the
book
i would like a systematic reading of
history a systemic reading of history
like a reading of history based on the
philosophy of systems not because i
think this is still very
modern in the sense that is is romantic
it has this notion of individual free
will and reason and
i think i think we need to overcome
modernity
urgently in so many fields
all right well while we're wrapping up
here i'm just saying i'm i'm feeling a
little bit more sentimental than i was
when we started the conversation and
it's and it's still left with the same
question that this what is this the
z-jack reading is uh
answers without questions like the
question really we're we're still left
with
you know wherever we live is what do we
do
it's not good wait wait so we can't just
talk about it i just no i'm not though
dude i'm not i'm not wrapping up
we don't okay wait
the question we're left with i guess is
just
what do we do
and i'll leave it with you victor
okay well i
like yeah so the graber book i have been
i actually have the audio book i haven't
i was listening to it like when i was uh
out cycling for but i haven't i need to
return to it um and i thought it was you
know it's interesting but i guess
yeah i just i find myself to be such a
skeptic of like these ideas oh we can
change our subjectivity so that we treat
people who are in our family like i
think our family like i just i mean i
don't know maybe that's that's that's
that's a that's a bastardization of what
you guys are saying but i just i think i
just am fundamentally very much a
pessimist about that about those kinds
of things like i think family is a
unique a unique thing and maybe in the
context of like a much smaller tribal
society right like that graeber's
talking about at these smaller places
but like in an advanced society
that just doesn't seem like a plausible
answer but just as a counter example
like what if we made online communities
that were localized like our discord for
example do you think people treat each
other
with different respect in there than
they would in like a
a larger market
just compare the conversations in 4chan
to the conversations in twitter
of course and and i think we want to
have a society where there's like people
can people can um
you know you know create social bonds in
these various like in fact there's a lot
of work uh in this in democratic theory
it's called like associational democracy
where they talk about you know like
building uh kind of like institutions
that allow for these like much smaller
groups of associative ties um that can
create like better conditions of
solidarity and like and like respect for
others and yeah i'm not i'm not
necessarily um
necessarily against against those things
but but i guess i just
i'm just less i'm less optimistic about
like what is going to be something
radically new that's another thing it's
like is there something
like new i think that i just think human
beings are the same like i just think
that like we live in human nature
uh well no so i believe in i believe
that there is a structure and that
limits human nature but i don't believe
in one set human nature so i think that
like merely pontine phenomenology
lacanian psychoanalysis show us the
limits the traces around which
this variety of human nature can operate
but it's not determined like it's not
like one thing it's many things but it's
limited by
and actually i take zx in some ways uh
philosophy to be talking about that like
like which is why i think he fi i i take
him to be sort of pessimistic like in
the reading we had today where he's like
you know like what like what do you want
these things are just falling into this
kind of fantasy where you're like oh i'm
gonna overthrow this and just like he
always loves talking about v for
vendetta right it's like what's gonna
happen after v for vendetta right it's
like the same what do you guys want yeah
exactly what do you guys want so so and
i think that we we rarely know what we
want i mean human beings are are are are
sick confused creatures that have no
idea what the [ __ ] they're doing and
they get they get pulled and influenced
by different different structures like i
so i agree with a lot of the analysis
but in terms of like something radically
new like i just think there's there's a
structure there's there's kind of a
thing that that you can work with this
kind of like outline of what a human
being subjectivity can be
and i think that there are ways that we
can make those things like better um so
and in that sense i'm like a moralist
but new radically different i'm just i'm
just kind of a skeptic i don't know what
that means i'm going to i'm going to try
to to answer both questions so so pills
asked what do we do
like what do we want right and and from
victor you get this skepticism of of
what could be and this
challenge of really new subjectivities
can we go there do they actually exist
do we want that okay so so to both i
don't really care about subjectivities
again i think the subject is a symptom
that then that's why i think what do we
want i want property like why do i want
property at least to have the safety
that there's an end to my work
at least i want that peace of mind to
say that i don't need to work until i
die like that that i can choose to to
dedicate my life to a different endeavor
that is not mandated upon me on the
basis of sounds like you don't just want
property for yourself you want property
for
every single person regardless of
ability
you exactly exactly that's exactly my
reading now of course i'm i'm the chaval
de trois i'm the the like the horse of
troy in the sense that if i if i am
white blue eyes 184 100 kilos
like i'm i'm
yeah
if i have all the
yeah if i have all the privileges of a
cisgender whatever
and i'm worried about property like
what i want to show is that uh
everybody's susceptible to this danger
anyone can be successful to this peril
of losing all property on things and
that's why i want to talk about property
my romantic philosophical logic to
explain it is that it will leave and
open up to new possibilities and new
subjectivities which is all very nice
maybe i'm completely wrong but in is is
a more
like the aim versus the goal like the
goal is the new subjectivity the end the
the aim the short term tactical
objective is survival is is a much
rather simple sense of i don't want to
be exhausted by my work until death i
want to be able to indulge myself in
boredom and say what the [ __ ] do i do
now because i'm not i'm not thinking
about food tomorrow or you know
existential threats to my life or to the
dignity of my son
like what what is that like
what is my life what is my mind capable
of if i can go to bed without worrying
about the dignity of my son's life
because he's disabled
what is that like that's that's what i
wonder that's what i want that that's
what excites me
that's what i think we should aim and
strive for because and and i think
property is what's going to open up
these possibilities because today
working till death is is the only thing
that is not negotiable this is the thing
that everybody has has made peace with
this in the back of their minds and we
just like we squander and we debate and
we talk about different things and we
find different interests but in the back
of our minds we're like oh my god i have
to make money out of whatever i do
otherwise you know to be homeless
i think we agree on the aims for sure
like you know i like i think that's kind
of maybe what i end up focusing on more
in in my own thinking is just like what
are some concrete aims that can help us
put ourselves in a better position for
people and like
you know i think you you were mentioning
i i was reminded of thomas piketty you
know that do you know this this
economist uh this kind of left-wing kind
of marxist economist i think he is
really interesting
good example no no no i think he's
marcus i don't think he's
definitely he's definitely very very
left-wing though very very no but he's
gay in asia not most i don't i most at
most so i mean
his analysis of capital is pretty like
um is is pretty much he's still adheres
he's still on the subjective value of of
of uh prices
is he he's not into the labor value
theory his subjective value of theory so
that itself excludes him from marxist
fair enough fair enough fair enough so
he's not a marxist economist but um but
he's left as you can say that's why
that's why it's complicated to have a
conversation with the anglo-left because
the anglo-left is mainly liberal and and
more and more in academic circles
liberal and marxist are like diametric
opposites
yeah yeah for sure i mean so but in
terms of aims i think that he he has
presented some some good concrete aims
he he talks about like the wealth
inheritance right where every person
would be born
uh and he does the math on it that you
would you would inherit automatically
from the state like 250 000
like when you reach age 18 right and
like he has a whole bunch of interesting
arguments about like how that would
enable people to uh he has really good
arguments too about like how inequality
is actually sometimes productive but
like way too much inequality is not
productive um like obviously that's
still within a capitalist paradigm all
that stuff but anyway i think it's a
name
my argument is always this like so so
yeah well i am skeptical about whatever
we want to call these new subjectivities
i still think that like people who are
concerned with this
need to be fighting and arguing four
things
that can put the working class the
people who are vulnerable right now in a
better position so that then they can
keep asking for more right which is like
so every little step on the way that
puts us in a stronger position when i
say us broadly in the sense that people
care about this
um we should be supporting and so and
then goals i guess maybe i just don't
know what the goal is i'm kind of a
skeptic i guess
well
it's it's very i think even mark said it
is the end of private property
communism is only that like be beyond
that claim i don't think communism is
anything else but the end of private
property that's it
the rest of the analysis in capital and
in the critical project of gota and even
in even in the articles we read for this
series so far like badu he never says
private property
he just says that the collective and
this is this is much more clear this
and this is this is and this is one of
the critiques people make about you that
badu is not really a marxist in the
traditional sense because if you don't
critique private property are what are
you talking about like what what's the
point like what are you aiming for i
don't think we're gonna like
critique because that's not what he was
trying to do which is the same thing i
argued about it it's unfair he's unfair
i'm
i'm i'm i'm miscarrying characterizing
but do a lot but but it's true that he's
been criticized under that notion that
he's not really a marxist or marxist
enough if he doesn't include a critique
on property
like at least he should mention it well
he he has a lot
and he's a he's a property yeah
well yeah
that that's the other thing that is
sometimes hard to swallow from badou
like i think i think it's it's it's also
hard to just
wash the failed attempts at leftism in
in the 20th century without being truly
a harsh critic of the all the mistakes
and but also you cannot fully just
dismiss them as as authoritarian regimes
and just not say well where were they
when they started where did they ended
like the different possibilities and
what i wanted to lead with this
conversation is you know this notion
from hegel that um
what is real is rational and what is
rational is real and then angles did the
the the rewriting as uh what is real is
rational and what is rational can be
real
like and and and this is this is my
reading about the notion of communism in
the sense that as much as it is rational
it can be real even if it's not
like for example the the aims we are
aiming for is that as much as we can
struggle
for new ownership
for property
then we can create the conditions for
for change to occur
and
this sounds very messianic and i always
struggle with this part because it it
requires a certain level of dogmatism
that i don't necessarily have because
it's it it in a way it requires a belief
in in prosperity and what and whatever
but i do believe in it's it's more
existential than that it's more uh
it's more urgent than that in the sense
of survival and that's that's why i'm
still trapped under this under under
this notion of the world
i say [ __ ] even the messianism
of it like i think
all of us work
this kind of job and all of us also are
maybe not you diego anymore but at least
you have you know what it feels like to
work for someone else and you know what
it feels like to work for yourself and
there's a completely different sense of
the world that arises from that when you
have the freedom because i have to go
back and forth uh i know victor has to
go
back and forth and if we could just do
like the ownership of labor
that creates a huge difference in um
you know the quality of life but also
if it fails there's nothing there's
nothing waiting for us under there
so i don't know i don't know what the
what the good world would be but i think
at least out of this discussion i
understand that that like property is
what makes
life worth living unfortunately
but it is the kind of thing that we have
to deal with
and
not only property in the sense of
ownership but property in the sense of
security like you're not going to die
and your kids are as simple as that and
you know the next generation
absolutely i just want to have this this
peace of mind of okay i'm not condemning
my kids to to starvation
like that
that sounds like a lot but
you know like
no totally i mean it seems like
something that we we all want and you
know i was thinking to
being a graduate student for so long
what a difference it would make uh to
like not worry to be able to pursue the
things that i want to pursue which is
why i do like the the kind of concrete
uh aims as you put it of
people of like you know i know we didn't
get into universal basic income which
there's pro but like even what you know
um picketty was proposing right like if
i inherited ubi you know 200 grand
uh you know like well how different my
life let's go let's go let's go into
detail into that victor okay so ubi and
inheritance of 2050 when you were born
if property is accumulated into one hand
don't you think inflation is going to
devour that in like a few
not only a few decades a generation if
you want that's a problem with universal
basic income that it doesn't account for
inflation or where does that money comes
from because you depend on taxation to
to raise your bi
like the the the challenge to ubi is ubs
no universal basic shareholding which is
a proposal that that because money in a
way it represents value but what we want
is property so what we should aim for is
not universal basic income as you have
uh least common denominators of your
subsistence but universal basic
shareholding in the sense that we can
collectively own these things
and then the the profit that comes out
get evenly distributed like are you guys
familiar with that with the
structure of a p l
profit and losses spreadsheet you mean
well shareholders for a company
or like even like basically when like
for example let's say okay so okay i
want to create the price of this right
so the p l like the pro the profit and
losses is how much labor cost how much
raw material cost how much uh process
liquid what are the distribution
marketing it accounts for everything
right so the p l accounts for every
profit and every loss within the product
but then on top of that we always add an
extra percentage for the shareholders
surplus
surplus service so surplus value but
look we could go into this but
talking about it again this is my oh
this is always my original question is
what is talking about it get us
well i think it's interesting i mean so
well it reveals it only reveals the
material conditions
yeah it doesn't change it just reveals
just and just to be fair to picketty i
know that that his argument about like
in terms of inflation like i don't know
it that well but i know a lot of the
math on his proposal will have to do
with like taxing inheritance taxes so
like a lot of rich families like they
inherit these huge amounts of wealth and
then they just pass it down to their
family without taxes and it's like he he
claims that he did the math and it's
like a lot like doing putting more of an
inheritance tax could pay for a lot of
that so like it wouldn't lead to like
more inflation it would just
redistribute um but sure i mean there's
problems with with ubi and other things
that have no absolutely and i think as
an aim as an intermediary aim it can be
it can bring a lot of good to a lot of
people that are really struggling right
now
brazil under bolsonaro fell back 30
years on nutrition
like we have as many malnourished people
today as we had 40 years ago
that's great brazil again got into the
problem of malnutrition because of a
right-wing president
this is this is is completely urgent
it's today it's actual it's it's result
of bad policy and of course if you want
and recession and whatnot but it would
it it didn't happen in every country in
latin america it happened mainly in
brazil so of course it has to do with
what brazil did right so so in that
sense i think of course ubi will
immediately help a lot of people will
solve the problem or just like
like delocate it or just like move it
somewhere else because it's it's always
strange when when when people talk about
this uh black legend you know the the
black legend of communism another 100
million debts and it's ridiculous made
up numbers by the caa and stuff so like
when you get into the numbers for
example for malnutrition
the statistic at the moment is that
eight million people die of hunger every
year
eight million okay and we're talking
about
we having the possibility and the
capacity to produce food for 10 billion
people
so we we can produce for 10 billion okay
and 8 million die per year and then the
four leading causes of death are
heart disease diabetes cancer and
alzheimer's
all of them are food related
so so
what's the point of having a system that
uses the market as a regulatory logic
that over produces and kills that people
that consume too much and kills people
that consume too little
because the profit because it's only
about profit it doesn't care about
people it it we're not even part of the
equation and and we're talking as if we
we were this is this is what is
monstrous to me
in the sense that
putting ourselves within the the
objectives of the market it's
it's the is the most narcissistic
argumentation ever
like it doesn't care it like we're not
even like we we're not even part of the
like we're one more variable that's it
that at most we're one more variable and
and i'm afraid of liberalism because we
tend to design institutions around the
logic of capital with the bias that the
market cares about us
that's my problem with liberalism but
diego isn't making a podcast about it
and all talking together it's the same
narcissism
it's like we're not gonna do anything
[Music]
it is but my other option was to work
for pepsico okay okay
i know so but i never whispered a choice
can i can i say can i say this is less
worst or not even less worse it's less
worse yes
it's less worse i don't know maybe maybe
i'm wrong like for example i look at
what i used to do and i'm ashamed like i
used to run p l's i use i use can you
imagine i used to change the packaging
sizes of products to outer size
impression and skill subjective value
you mean like putting air in a bag of
chips
yeah and changing the proportions of the
rectangle so people think the the value
of what i was buying was more than it
what actually was
right
so just to go i can i can safely say
what you're doing now is much better so
thank you
yeah and i hope and i hope that after
the documentary i learned about
something new and that i can eventually
do something more about it and this
notion that i no longer defend woke-ism
and progressism and i want to move into
real discussions about how we can change
the relationships of property i hope it
can be better but
otherwise what what else do we do right
what else we dream about also
ascertainism no thanks
yeah yeah fair i will just say on
liberalism very quickly
i think that that word it's you have to
i think that like
often uh people who are sympathetic to
like marxism i think they end up
conflating it with neoliberalism
and i think that like all i mean by
liberalism is just like um a framework
that protects people from the arbitrary
power of the state and i think that like
liberalism does a good job
with protecting people from arbitrary
state power a very bad job of protecting
people from arbitrary corporate power
and i think that that's like a flaw in
liberalism that that like that i agree
with you that i'm sympathetic to but i
still think that like that overall
framework um is important which is why i
still you know flirt with with
identifying myself as that because
because i do care about arbitrary power
victor did you hear what i said lately
sometime recently it was like
all of the rhetoric was to protect from
state power but it was
also to protect them from the poors
oh sure it's a bourgeoisie ideology yeah
i don't want to be unfair to liberalism
because i also i also understand that i
know there's several different types of
liberalism is it's completely unfair to
carry characterizer as one school of
thought because it's it's a very diverse
i've read some of it but not in all of
it i'm sure and i and i know i'm i'm
painting a caricature picture of
liberalism right now just to oppose it
and it and it's unfair and you're right
to make a remark but but but having said
that i i agree we can use liberalism
against itself until a certain degree
but we do we do need some goals in
common beyond the tactical aims you know
totally beyond that beyond the tactical
little steps like
little victories here and there are
awesome lula one in brazil we have boric
in chile you know we have uh petro in
colombia like beyond those tactical
victories we have to go beyond and say
okay good so now lula is still
negotiating who owns the amazon but now
he's negotiating with uh with with some
benefits to the brazilian people and
he's like dude really
okay another another very simple example
the city i mean right now is called
monterrey in mexico actually matt used
to teach here if i'm not wrong
the uh
mexico city campus the mexico city
campus
i was mexico city it was not there
wasn't any worse
than mexico
okay cool yeah so uh so i went to the
same university but here in monterrey
where the is the is the hometown of that
university and at the moment here in the
city we have water cuts every day
so i only have water in my house from
four in the morning till 11 a.m
then i don't have water in my house the
rest of the day
yeah
right now it has been like that all
summer and it's probably gonna be like
that until september when we get water
again with the rains okay and i'm
talking about the third biggest city in
mexico we have over six million people
living here
and it's a very wealthy city actually
the the the little uh the one of the
little spaces in the city is one of the
wealthiest neighborhoods in all of latin
america so it's not a shady
backyard type of notice super well
developed cities with lamborghinis and
ferraris on the street and we have water
from 4 a.m till 11 a.m in the morning
every morning but at the same time
it's in this city where we have heineken
and
coca-cola and they consume
millions of liters of water and they're
constantly asking us for take faster
showers
wow like
again like like this this is my this is
my concern with neoliberalism is that is
the instrumentalization of the state to
permit the proliferation of capital
interests and and this is the limit of
and this is this is in the end the limit
of current existing democracies
current existing democracies they only
operate as a by-product or as a
subsystem of the capitalist system
that's it because campaigns cost money
and money asks for something in return
so somebody has to fund the politicians
and the politicians they get into power
and they already own everything that
they have all the power that they have
they own
and and and of course as the state
cannot fund campaigns and campaigns are
more and more expensive
whoever funds the the candidate owns the
candidate once he's in power so of
course when you get when you get these
problems of water shortages that is
again a result of
pulse industrialization or whatever you
want
who's like we we romanticize and we
create these fantasies and narratives to
explain it and we end up with the logic
and auto you have to take faster showers
but then again one liter of coca-cola
requires 200 liters of water and one
kilogram of meat requires almost 10 000
liters of water
and it's like yeah and again we're
producing food to feed 10 billion people
and we starve 8 million per year and the
four leading causes of their are food
related this is why is like
economy is worse than astrology it's it
it's the worst
it's like who the hell like like oh my
god it's insane i i feel like i'm
trapped in this insanity it sounds like
you might be able to call that
like a contradiction
maybe
just maybe if somebody was only brave
enough to come up with these criticisms
who will be the guy i can't wait i'm
looking forward to it
an analysis of contradictions where
where where are you yeah
and that's why we should make podcasts
we should we should make people aware of
these contradictions at least i don't
want to wake up to somebody to tell me
you have to work harder
like
at least i don't want to hear that like
i would love to get somebody to explain
to my son
that he has to work harder in order not
to starve i would love to see that i
will pay any motivational speaker to
come to my house and give a lecture to
my son that doesn't speak and he cannot
understand because of genetic condition
and explain to him how he has to pull
himself up by his bootstraps i will pay
any amount of money to see that
no i'll record it i will make the most
viral video ever he should have been on
crypto i'm curious
well i don't i mean i i need to wrap up
soon but um in mexico do they not have
like social assistance i'm just curious
like is it is it like because i know
like in canada i feel like there's like
pretty robust like like what i think
they call it legally like disability but
like i don't know i don't know what's
what it's like does that not exist in
britain in mexico no yeah yeah it does
but can you imagine like even right now
i'm
i'm fighting a couple of like i already
passed a couple of of intentions of law
none of them got approved so far uh
but i i got one to protect victims of
coexif cults like people that fall into
these pyramid schemes and
theological codes and everything i i try
to pass a lot to protect them and to
penalize people that organize pyramid
schemes but then again capitalism is a
pyramid scheme so it was kind of uh were
you successful in passing in getting
those laws passed or no no it got it got
to the floor it got discussed into the
floor it got a lot of traction but then
it went nowhere and now i'm trying to
pass a law and and change our
legislation to change the name from
disability to differently able right and
it's just a matter of simple dignity you
know it's like
we still call them disabled which is
insulting it's like
like when is your son it's like it burns
i cannot i cannot explain it this is
just like it's infuriating you know so
this is one of the battles that i want
to to to pass but then again is to raise
awareness on a bigger problem that we're
all going to be disabled very quickly
pills what do you think
i think we
recorded a podcast yeah i just mean it's
not unfair to say that it probably
completely changed the world
um and and no to be serious
at least we got a little bit outside of
the anglo box for
about two hours two hours holy [ __ ]
um i want to thank diego so much for
coming here if you've been
uh i don't know like what do you say am
i inspired by you diego no i'm kind of
like
ah don't say that i mean where you're
getting oppressed by everything that you
just said so it's not it's not like i'm
being breathed in by the holy spirit
here it's more like oh god now what
but uh anyway to our listeners if you
want to
uh catch up with diego last week he
released a youtube channel in english
uh do you know what the name is diego
diego rusarin english so diego zara
simple english
yeah simple as that we could we couldn't
come up with any other like catchy
catchy things like what would you say
like brazilian marxist pessimist
non-leftist fatalist
anyway uh diego i want to thank you so
much we've been going for what like
almost three hours now so it was such a
pleasure to talk to you
in person instead of on
instagram dms
and uh
yeah victor also like uh
defending your view of liberalism to you
know the trash talkers
it's the easiest thing to trash talk and
you always dig your feet in and you
always got your feet in the right place
it's it's so enjoyable it was really an
absolute pleasure uh to talk to you
diego and i hope we can have an
opportunity to do something like this
again uh because it was a lot of fun i
feel like there's a lot more to talk
about but if we're just running out yeah
we'll come on your english
channel yeah please do and actually
you remember i think i told you about
this a while ago pills that i'm
organizing a live event in mexico in
september and i'm bringing i'm bringing
in a couple of friends from uh spain
germany and
argentina to have a discussion about um
iberofonia like the um
the ibero world like what do we do as
spanish as as
spanish speakers what do we do where do
we go from here where do where do we
think from like what does it what does
it imply to think in spanish
is is there some level of
autonomy that we can aspire to what do
we do politically like where do we rally
like what aims what goals what type of
objectives can we create and construct
together that make sense for us as a
region because because again like i feel
like latin america
was for the last almost hundred years
the backyard of the us
and now that the us and and the
neoliberal hegemony is like
showing cracks in the armor and we are
like truly
opening up to alternatives like we we
can discuss if if china is a better or
worse alternative but at least it's an
alternative
we we you we do we didn't have those
like we used to live in countries that
were constant targets for coup d'etats
from the us and we still had to go back
and make business with them because we
have no choice
now we have choices at least now we can
say okay you keep doing this and we are
going to keep building this hate towards
you and this is going to be detrimental
to our commercial
possibilities and it's going to be more
expensive to you to build up your
reputation in my region
at least now we have possibilities so
possibilities are are better in the
sense that they're not stagnated in time
they're not trapped
they
they break us away from this sense of
empty nostalgia that is addictive that
we are just like falling again and again
until those same same problems and same
questions and i think it's an
interesting moment for latin america
we're having like this
latin american spring you can say
and at the moment we are looking at
latin america with different eyes so my
invitation is for people to
to to to take a look at the region with
with a different set of eyes with a
different set of possibilities
and and i i prefer change than
repetition
yeah i mean i gotta say we're looking at
you because
what the hell are we doing
awesome and i i just subscribed to your
english youtube channel and i see that
you had an interview with dj tiesto
which is kind of interesting i have no
idea what the content is but
yeah i used to i used to love going to
raves back in the day so i saw him live
a couple times but it's been a while my
content is the most rainbow thing ever
like i will do like i loved i love music
so i do a lot of song analysis like what
i do is that i read the lyrics of songs
and i i do like the
psychoanalytical and philosophical
analysis of lyrics of some of some songs
but i have done like from super like
these deep songs from
niche cult groups and i have analysis of
songs from reggaeton and popular culture
i'm really not an elitist here i really
believe all music has some static value
so i tried to do analysis from the first
one and that's how i got an interview
with tiesto in las vegas but i also do
for example analysis of animes of movies
of books
i do live review of news so i just open
news report every morning and i live
react to what's happening in the news
which is super fun because it's kind of
this topic and it's like uh baudrillard
sense of this is where the world is
actually happening in cnn so it's quite
fun so you will see in my channel a lot
of mix of everything and i just wanted
to say thank you guys for the for the
invitation it was super nice i i
reinstate the fact that i'm a super fan
of the of the peel pod
it's one of my favorite things to listen
to when i'm in the gym or while i'm
driving it's a pity that the other two
guys could not be here i i extend the
invitation that we can repeat the talk
and have another conversation on my
channel we have great great pleasure
all right excellent i gotta say thank
you so much for uh dealing with my
technical in capacity
and uh
yeah i'll talk to you soon
sure
see ya
and to the listeners uh thank you so
much for listening this has been great i
hope it was great for you also and uh
you'll hear from us
when you do
[Music]